Okay,
all right.
What the hell address the Jewish
question?
That's a hell of a thing to ask.
So that's Jacqueline.
You know,
I mean really that's a hell of a thing
to ask,
but I will say something about it.
You know,
and I thought about this a lot.
So there is evidence that Ashkenazi
Jews,
so those are Jews of European heritage,
have iqs that are about 15 points higher
than the population average.
So that's a lot.
15 points.
It's about the average difference
between the typical high school student
and the typical state college student.
It's a lot.
And one of the things that means is,
so imagine there's two distributions and
that they overlap and that the Jewish
one is,
uh,
is the mean is 1:15.
So the whole distribution has shifted to
the right.
What that means is if you go up into the
Higher Iq strata,
1:30,
1:45
way the hell up there,
that Jewish people are overwhelmingly
overrepresented at the high end of the
ICU distribution.
Now the price they pay for that is some
increased propensity for neurological
diseases that seems to be associated in
some sense with that heightened Iq.
Now you know,
the science on this isn't settled but,
but it,
it's reasonably solid.
It given the standards of such things.
Okay,
so Jews are going to be our over
represented at the high end of
cognitively complex disciplines.
So then I would say,
and that's the case,
like they're way over represented among
like outstanding scientists and among
Nobel Prize winners and and so forth.
And so you know,
people look and they think,
well why are there a disproportionate
number of Jewish people in positions of
authority?
And they say,
well,
it must be a conspiracy.
You know,
it must be systemic in some sense.
It's like,
no,
it can be simply accounted for by that
relatively large ICU differential.
Now the next criticism would be,
well,
don't the Jews tend to lean left?
Well first you might say,
well,
you know,
given what happened in Nazi Germany to
the degree that that was right wing as
we discussed earlier,
that's the nationalism and
ethnocentrism.
It's hardly surprising that they might,
you know,
in this historical period of time tend
to move towards the left,
but more importantly than that,
Iq is associated with trait,
openness and trade.
Openness is a strong predictor predictor
of political liberalism.
So,
and it's the strongest predictor of
political liberalism.
So,
you know,
it's very difficult.
So that's what I have to say about that.
It's like,
and the other thing I would say is,
you know,
the fact that there is a population of
subpopulation of people who are much
smarter than average,
not on average,
right?
On average,
I've got to get that straight on average
is actually a great benefit to the rest
of us because why do you want fewer
geniuses?
Fewer people with Iqs of 145 or 160.
That's and you know,
and it's no conspiracy that puts people
who are smarter,
higher up in competence hierarchies
because I accused the best predictor of
movement in a complex carb competence
hierarchy.
So there,
I've addressed the Jewish question.
It's like it's a confusion between
ethnicity and and ICU as far as I'm
concerned.
So I'll probably get like painted six
different shades of black for that
answer,
but it's.
I've thought about a long time.
It's the best that I can manage.